throughout history there have been
many incredible civilizations that have
shaped
the way we live today one
was ancient rome a once majestic
and thriving city whose strong
foundations live on to this day
yet despite all its grandeur life
as an average citizen in ancient rome
was
hard and unforgiving
what strange customs did the romans have
what was the life expectancy of an
average citizen
and what did the romans do for fun
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you lived in ancient rome
let's imagine you woke up sometime
between 27
bce and 180 ce
the golden age of rome known
in latin by the romans as pax romana
or roman peace this epoch
began when augustus came into power
after his father the
infamous julius caesar was assassinated
with augustus on the throne rome began a
period of rapid development
at its peak it was home to over 1
million people
it was a truly golden era of
architecture
science art entertainment and economic
growth
it was a time of peace and prosperity
if you were rich okay so
what's the catch well unless you were
part of the one percent that controlled
16 of rome's wealth life
was tough as a citizen up to 50 percent
of all roman children
died before the age of 10 and most
adults were lucky
if they lived long enough to see their
50s even though things were
peaceful battles still happened and
soldiers were in demand
roman armies at this point were largely
made up of volunteers who were hoping
for
a better chance at life most soldiers
came from the poorest social class
and were stationed at the borders of the
empire where
the most trouble was expected as a
soldier
you were able to settle in the land
where you were stationed
once you retired and if you were
particularly good with a sword or a bow
you might be hand-picked to join the
special forces
designed to protect the emperor or maybe
to climb the ranks as a gladiator
they were treated like celebrities
well at least the ones that survived
with a large portion of the men away
from home working as
soldiers women gained more autonomy
during this period
serving important roles as city
councilors lawyers
teachers and more some women were even
gladiators
however the men in the family still had
the privilege of
handling the matters of property and
finance
most of the poor lived in cheap wooden
houses
many of them lived in the city slums
where crime was rampant
you might find the emperor augustus's
police force or
cohorts urbane patrolling some parts of
the city but
generally the poorer areas were lawless
and dangerous
whether you were a soldier philosopher
or senator
most romans ate a similar diet of bread
cheese grapes nuts olives and meat
if you could afford it you could eat out
at one of the many bakeries in the city
to wash things down you'd have the
option of thick
milk watered wine or fruit juice
that doesn't sound too bad to me after
lunch many romans went to the bath house
to swim
play sports bathe or get a massage
and dinner was just a few hours later
around 4 or 5
p.m in the afternoon okay where do i
sign up
while many romans had this luxury
a large portion of them were slaves or
clients for rich families in this
patron client system people were sold
and
forced to help with all kinds of work
from hard menial labor to
highly skilled jobs like teachers
accountants and doctors
if they were lucky their patrons would
give them a good dinner and they would
go home with
pockets full of food and if they did
really well they would
eventually be freed some poor people
were desperate enough to sell their
children in times of hardship
speaking of hardship if you needed to
use the washroom
you could visit one of rome's public
toilets
housing over 10 toilet seats out in the
open
oh that's intimate these weren't exactly
the cleanest toilets and instead of
toilet paper
romans had a stick with a sponge at the
end that they would share
[Music]
i'll stick with my bidet please
and when it was time to clean up many
romans used urine
from humans or animals to decontaminate
surfaces
treat infections and even to wash their
laundry
it might sound strange but urea in urine
breaks down into ammonia a strong
cleaning agent
found in most cleaning supplies today
and if you happen to get sick with
epilepsy
you might be prescribed some gladiator's
blood or
liver to consume ah thanks but
no thanks doc if you managed to save up
a little money
you could go shopping at the trajan's
market
the first ever mall in the world
or if you were craving more excitement
[Music]
how about a chariot race at the circus
maximus
or an epic gladiator battle maybe
some theater and for the budget minded
there were plenty of public executions
to go around
but if history is your entertainment of
choice
have you ever wondered what the world
would be like if christopher
columbus never discovered america
[Music]
well that sounds like a story for
another
what if
you